kickboxing is one of the most brutal and
dangerous sports in the world but what
does it take to be a professional
fighter can someone with no experience
really become a genuine contender in one
of the bloodiest of sports
[Applause]
cold Karen and I was watching YouTube
video after YouTube video of people
training and people fight towards myself
this is stupid
this isn't the way to prepared every
fire needs a trainer I'm not with him
and I'm worried that when he's on his
own it starts to get isolated we need
sacked with this self-doubt head-on
so I've asked the best kickboxing coach
in South Africa to help I'm sending in
to train with Steve calico I don't yeah
it's my way or the highway
okay you're gonna spar with velocity
should I give it course she got hit in
the face a couple of times and he wanted
to retaliate is a good point to say that
I don't wanna do this anymore punches
he's not using his hips
she's not using his legs really he
doesn't perfect when he punched me just
using John singles now it's got two more
to walk off women needs to build
injuries back up meanwhile veteran coach
Steve color coder gets to work on
interest technical weaknesses look at
your shoulders is like this like that
slowly it seems injuries is starting to
regain some self belief with the doubts
of South Africa behind him there's a
specific reason for coming to Cuba
Kieran is worried about interés lack of
mobility in the ring
but simply he's just too easy to hit
vamos elemento primero either purple
gold noep white OS pasado whole tree the
constant repetition develops muscle
memory so eventually Idris should do it
without thinking psychology is so
important is nothing like an actual fire
to focus the mind if a dress is going to
step into the ring with a pro in eight
months time first he needs to get an
armor to fight under his belt when once
he gets back to London that's exactly
what his trainer Kieran wants him to do
the contest will be scored by three
judges and a ref in the event of a
knockout they won't be needed please
welcome making his way to the blue
corner Patrick how 14 fighting out of
Hackney East London making his way to
the red corner Idris Elba
[Applause]
[Music]
Plus straight out the blocks
it just went through it Idris was
composed it was focused
uses Jack well and it started to find
his range
until around 20 Hertz mmm-hmmm hands on
your head in the second round it was
hard to tell if it was on top
[Applause]
both fighters were getting tired and
making loads of mistakes when edgers
come back to the corner he was spent to
be honest it didn't look like yet
another round in him just keep your head
up keep your form fairy shots now don't
have to build power shots yeah make him
off against the ropes throw that kick if
you're close foe your knee doing great
[Music]
and sure enough in the third round
addresses God dropped just ten seconds
from the end of the final round
Idris went down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you